hi this is going to be a video about the
push to hub api for tensorflow and keras
so to get started we'll open up our
notebook
and the first thing you'll need to do is
log into your hugging face account for
example with the notebook login function
um so to use that
you simply call the function the pop-up
will emerge you i'll enter your username
and password which i'm going to pull out
of my password manager here
and you log in
the next two cells are just getting
everything ready for training so we're
just going to load a data set we're
going to tokenize that data set and then
we're going to load our model and
compile it with a standard atom
optimizer so i'm just going to run all
of those
we'll wait a few seconds
and everything should be ready for
training
okay
so
now we're ready to train uh i'm going to
show you the two ways you can push your
model to the hub so the first is with
the push to hub callback
so a callback in keras
is a function that's called regularly
during training you can set it to be
called after a certain number of steps
or every epoch or even just once at the
end of training
um
so a lot of callbacks in keras for
example control learning rate decaying
on plateau
and things like that
so this callback by default will save
your model to the hub once every epoch
and that's really helpful because
especially if your training run is very
long because it means you can resume
from that save so you get this automatic
cloud saving of your model and you can
even run inference uh with the the
checkpoints of your model that have been
uploaded by this call this callback
and that means you can you know add do
run some test inputs and i actually see
how your model works at various stages
during training which is a really nice
feature
so
we're going to add the push-to-hope
callback and it takes just a few
arguments so the first argument is the
temporary directory that um files are
going to be saved to before they're
uploaded to the hub the second argument
is the tokenizer and the third argument
is here is the keyword argument the hub
model id so that's the name it's going
to be saved under on the hugging face
hub
you can also upload to an organization
account
um just by adding the organization name
before the repository name with a slash
like this so you probably don't have
permissions to upload to the hugging
face organization if you do please
follow a bug and let us know extremely
urgently
but if you do have access to your own
organization then you can use that same
approach to upload models to their
account instead of to your own personal
um
set of models
so
once you've made your callback you
simply um add it to the callbacks list
when you're calling model.fit and
and everything is uploaded for you from
there and there's nothing else to worry
about
the second way to upload a model though
is to call model.push2hub
so this is more of like a once-off
method
it's not called regularly during
training you can just call this manually
whenever you want to upload a model to
the hub
so we recommend
running this after the end of training
um just to make sure that you like you
have a commit message to guarantee that
this was the final version of the model
that was at the end of training and it
just makes sure that you know you're
you're working with the definitive end
of training model and not accidentally
using a checkpoint from somewhere along
the way
um
so i'm going to run both of these cells
and then i'm going to cut the video here
just because training is going to take a
couple of minutes so i'll skip forward
to the end of that when the models have
all been uploaded and i'm going to show
you how you can
access the models in the hub and the
other things you can do with them from
there
okay we're back
our model was uploaded and both by the
push to hope callback and also by our
call to model.push2hub after training
so everything's looking good so now if
we drop over to
my profile and hugging face and you can
get there just by clicking the profile
button in the drop down we can see that
the burt fine-tuned cola model is here
as updated three minutes ago
so it will always be at the top of your
list because they're sorted by how
recently they were updated
and we can start querying our model
immediately
so
uh
the
data set we were training on is the
blue cola data set and cola is an
acronym standing for the corpus of
linguistic acceptability uh so what that
means is the model is being trained to
decide if a sentence is sort of
grammatically or linguistically okay or
if there's a problem with it
uh for example
we could say
this is a legitimate sentence and
hopefully it realizes that this is in
fact a legitimate sentence
um
so it might take a couple of seconds for
the model to load when you call it for
the first time
so i might cut a couple of seconds out
of this video here
okay we're back
so the model loaded and we got an output
um but there's an obvious problem here
so these labels
aren't really telling us
you know what categories the model has
actually assigned to this input sentence
so if we want to fix that we want to
make sure the model config
has the correct names for each of the
label classes and then we want to upload
that config
so we can do that down here to get the
label names um we can get that from the
the data set we loaded um from the the
features attribute it has and then we
can create the two
dictionaries id to label and label to id
and just assign them to the model config
and then we can just push our updated
config and that will overwrite the
existing config in the
hub repo so that's just been done
so now if we go back here i'm going to
use a slightly different sentence
because sentences are and the outputs
for sentences are sometimes cached and
so
if we want to generate new results i'll
just use something slightly different so
let's try an incorrect sentence
so this is not valid english grammar and
hopefully the model will decide it's
going to reload it here so i might cut a
couple of seconds again
and then we'll see what the model has to
say
okay
so the model its confidence isn't very
good because of course we you know we
didn't really optimize our hyper
parameters at all and but it has decided
that this sentence is more likely to be
unacceptable than acceptable
um presumably if we tried a bit harder
with training we could get a much lower
validation loss and therefore the
model's predictions would be more
precise but let's try our original
sentence again
of course because of the caching issue
we're seeing that the original answers
are
unchanged so let's try a different valid
sentence
so let's try this is a valid english
and we see that now the model correctly
decides that it has a very high
probability of being acceptable and a
very low probability of being
unacceptable
so
you can use this inference api even with
the checkpoints that are uploaded during
training so it can be very interesting
to see how
the model's predictions for sample
inputs change
with each ebock of training
also the model we've uploaded is going
to be accessible to you and if it's
shared publicly to anyone else and so if
you want to load that model um all you
or anyone else needs to do
is just to you can either load it in a
pipeline or you can
just load it with for example tf auto
model for sequence classification
and then instead for the name you would
just simply pass
the path to the repo you want to upload
or to download excuse me so if we if a
if i want to use this model again if i
want to load it from the hub i just run
that one line of code
the model will be downloaded
and
with any luck it'll be ready to
fine-tune under different data set make
predictions with or do anything else you
want to do
so
that was a quick overview of how after
your training or during your training
you can upload models to the hub you can
checkpoint there you can resume training
from there and you can
get inference results from the models
you've uploaded
so thank you and i hope to see you in a
future video